tom and april were excellent witnesses
in my defense
unfortunately every single word out of
their mouths was a lie there's only one
thing i hate more than lying
skim milk which is water that's lying
about being milk
red meat can cause sluggishness heart
disease even impotence
has the opposite effect on me
you ever tried a turkey burger is that a
fried turkey leg inside a grilled
hamburger if so yes delicious leslie
needs to butt out the whole point of
this country is if you want to eat
garbage balloon up to 600 pounds and i
have a heart attack at 43 you can you
are free to do so
to me that's beautiful rage poise
property rights fish for sport only not
for meat fish meat is practically a
vegetable just a second
hey no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
oh my god i'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling
dentist pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see tom faint
[Laughter]
look a clock
we don't have that in america
oh wow look at that you shaved off part
of your mustache that's lovely i didn't
shave it off
it rubbed off
from friction
and you're oh
and
you're thoughtful and you're always such
a delight to have around i am sure you
are going to be an incredible mother
thanks larry that's nice goodbye anne
i have enjoyed parts of our time
together
oh oh god ron
that was really something
hey if you see andy will you not tell
him i'm here
okay because of what happened i don't
want him to think stop
don't want to know
the less i know about other people's
affairs the happier i am i'm not
interested in caring about people
i once worked with a guy for three years
and never learned his name
best friend i ever had
we still never talk sometimes
haircuts there are three acceptable
haircuts high and tight crew cut buzz
cut are the scissors broken in your
house son
ron you're constructing the stage yes
ma'am leslie wanted to hire a contractor
to build a stage
i don't want to paint with a broad brush
here but every single contractor in the
world is a miserable incompetent thief
don't go back to sleep okay i need you
to wake up ron come on help me
attaboy
i am only here because i owe leslie a
thousand favors i'm not big on charities
give a man a fish and you feed him for a
day
don't teach a man to fish and you feed
yourself
he's a grown man fishing's not that hard
oh my god whose baby is that that would
be mine guys get in here run as a baby
oh ron cool baby thank you andrew
everyone i'd like to introduce you to my
son
john middle name redacted swanson john
was born some time ago weighing multiple
pounds and several ounces much like his
father he is a fan of silence please
keep your voices down ron you have to
help me chris is making me do some
stupid management training leadership
course now that you run the animal
control department you have qualified
for the chris traeger management
training seminar or ketumps yeah it's
not a great acronym but it is a great
seminar
can you get me out of it
yes
normally if given a choice between doing
something and nothing i choose to do
nothing but i will do something if it
helps someone else do nothing i'd work
all night if it meant nothing got done
and i'll have the number eight that's a
party platter it serves 12 people i know
what i'm about son
i have cried twice in my life
once when i was seven and i was hit by a
school bus
and then again when i heard that little
sebastian had passed
his memory
will live on
as today we light a fire
that will burn on for eternity oh my god
if any of you need anything at all
too bad
deal with your problems yourselves like
adults oh hey little guy hey what are
you doing oh no
everyone meet your meat oh oh no
why are you doing this to us well in my
opinion not enough people have looked
their dinner in the eyes and considered
the circle of life this is your dinner
his name is tom
bern
seriously no i understand that it's
hilarious but that is his given
christian name tom is very smart and
incredibly loyal he's basically a dog a
dog we're going to cook chew and swallow
ron i'm so so sorry
what the
were you thinking
i would prefer that she asked me for my
permission
so i can say no
i like saying no
it lowers their enthusiasm
which one of you youngsters wants to
help me drain the blood from this animal
if you do a good job i'll give you the
bladder you can blow it up for a fun
play ball hey ron you're not gonna
slaughter that pig here are you not to
worry i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want i am
the director of the parks department and
this is a park spending the day outside
alone sounds like a dream
i love being a father but there are a
few things i miss silence
the absence of noise
one single moment undisturbed by the
sounds of a children's tv program called
doc mcstuffins
there is no quiet anymore
there is only doc mcstuffins
the game is absurd this gun is
lightweight there's no sight and we are
far too close to these deer would they
not smell us
i want my money back how do i get my
quarters oh my god you are such a sore
loser i'm not a sore loser it's just
that i prefer to win and when i don't i
get furious employee i haven't had lunch
since yesterday so i'm gonna head over
to callahan's oh no no don't go there
they totally skimp on pickles let me go
to bighead joes for you they have the
most
insane burritos i don't much go for
ethnic food
trust me they have one that's called the
meat tornado
literally killed a guy last year
you had me at meat tornado
i enjoy government functions like i
enjoy getting kicked in the nuggets with
a steel toe boot
but this hotel always serves
bacon-wrapped shrimp
that's my number one favorite food
wrapped around my number three favorite
food i'd go to a banquet and honor those
somali pirates if they serve
bacon-wrapped shrimp excuse me come on
everybody let's hustle let's get to the
brainstorming
great attitude ron
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible so i can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me it's like yoga
except i still get to kill something
great news ron jean-ralphio loves your
shirt what the hell are you talking
about oh i've been taking pictures of
you all day for my new facebook album
ron swan getting off the grid
tom
do you maybe see a problem with what
you've done
i do now yes sorry
erase
erase
erase
erase all pictures of ron
erase all pictures of ron
erase all pictures of ron
what the hell is happening he
accidentally opened a vine
you just find your first selfie ron and
i'm finding you vine yourself the world
is a nightmare
[Laughter]
erase all pictures
you